hi I'm Jacob Lambert I'm an R&D
scientist in the genome and epigenome
editing group of millibar Sigma and I'm
happy to talk to you today in this lab
roots oncology webinar but some of the
work we've been doing here and to show
you some exciting new technologies and
techniques specifically I'm going to
tell you all about a highly efficient
and specific to genome editing with cast
line nikkei's ribonucleoproteins in
primary key cells we've recently
submitted a paper this data to the bio
archive but I'm going to take you
through it all today this is a
combination of a multitude of different
technologies and advances so let's go
over the components first let's talk
about what are cast line decays forever
nuclear proteins starting off with the
most basic of basics I know that most of
you will be familiar with all of this
already but just in case I'm going to
give everyone a quick rundown of CRISPR
cast line what it is and how it works
the most common description you see in
all of the media headlines set they are
molecular scissors used in gene editing
which is pretty accurate CRISPR stands
for clustered regularly interspaced
short palindromic repeats but what does
that mean it's a native system found in
many bacterial species that functions as
an adaptive immune system against
invading viral DNA in the native
bacterial Krister CRISPR systems
identify past invading foreign viral DNA
and cleave it rendering it harmless but
this cleavage has been exploited in
eukaryotic cells to create RNAi guided
site-specific genetic manipulations but
what exactly does the cleavage
those are castes or CRISPR associated
nucleuses as you can see here in this
diagram the new places are guided to a
specific DNA sequence by a complementary
guide RNA once at this target the two
cleaving domains showcased here in the
diagram roof C and H and H cleave each
strand of DNA at the target
site forming a double-stranded break any
resulting genetic change relies on the
host cells or pair machinery in
mammalian cells either non-homologous
end joining or homology directed repair
the first causes random short insertions
and deletions and the second utilizes a
repair template that the CRISPR users
supply to fix the break more precisely
resulting in integration of a sequence
cache line this specifically is
currently the most popular variety of
the casting places as PCAST lion from
streptococcus pyogenes but it can have
off target cleavage activity with enough
complementarity between the intended
site and the genomic site at another
location in order to deal with this off
targeting issue there are several
different routes that researchers have
taken to produce these effects one such
route is using a paired cast line
Mackay's system cast line the case is a
mutated version of cast line with a d-10
a mutation which renders the roof see
cutting domain of SP cast line inactive
I doing so full targeting and efficiency
of the nuclease is retained while only a
single-stranded cut in the DNA is made
the nucleus can still find and cut the
target site but only one strand of DNA
is and we call this a nick with this
change however different cellular
machinery is activated to repair the
single-stranded break base excision
repair instead of nhej a.j or HDR which
causes insertions and deletions the
single-stranded break repair
perfectly repairs the DNA as the correct
template is always there on the other
strand in order to combat this you have
to use in a case to somehow induce
double-stranded break repair which is
where the Parana case strategy comes in
to do this you need to design to guide
RNAs with a 5 prime to 5 prime
orientation as shown here and have the
Pam's ranging from 30 to 150 base pairs
apart by doing
so you will have one Necaise cut the top
strand and the other cut the bottom
strand doing this within this base pair
window has been shown to trigger
double-stranded break repair mechanisms
instead of just single strand prepare
this method combats the off targeting of
SP cast line by requiring pairs to come
together to Nick together in order for
any editing to occur any off target
Nick's in the genome will not have the
adjacent other Nick and only the
single-stranded mechanisms will trigger
or no editing can occur the probability
of off targets meeting in this pair
criteria is extremely low in the human
genome therefore this is a highly
specific method of genome editing and
has been around for a couple of years
another newer method that we combine
this with is to use cast line
ribonucleoproteins traditionally cast
line nucleases are delivered via
plasmids or mRNAs that encode for the
protein and guide sequences these
methods rely on host cell machinery to
transcribe and/or translate have been
tailored to function in each specific
silk ear I believe I ribonucleoprotein
is a recombinant cast line protein that
has been complex with the targeting
guide RNA before delivery to cells there
are traditionally many problems that
occur when you use plasmids or mRNAs
there can be random integration of DNA
into the host which is unwanted if you
want to do more than just focus on the
exact also be toxicity issues many cell
types reject undergo apoptosis when
introduced a foreign DNA especially
primary cells and this toxicity can also
provoke immune responses in the host
organisms also when you introduce
plasmids or mRNA there will also be
continual expression which increases off
target probability the cellular
machinery will continue to express the
cache landing guy that you introduce to
the cell
well this is great for making sure that
there are plenty of copies for cutting
your target site the extreme excess of
copies dramatically increases the
possibilities of a partial match
occurring somewhere along Gino
increasing the likelihood of an off
target genetic effect you can combat
this by using an RMP they are much more
universal they were work with any cell
with DNA there's no need for expression
it's the only thing you'll have to
design is the target itself they also
cut immediately after delivery as they
bypass transcription and translation
they are ready to find the target site
and cut immediately after delivery
they also rapidly degrade the continual
expression issues of the other methods
aren't something one has to worry about
when working with our MPs they don't
stick around long enough to find much
more than the exact sequence before they
are degraded by the cell these are
rapidly becoming the new standard method
of delivery especially in primary cell
types so we decided to make any case
version of an esky cast 9 RMP but the
first thing the first thing we had to do
was make sure that it worked properly
before we did any test advanced testing
in cells we first had to verify their
cleaving abilities in general we needed
to make sure that the d-10 a mutation
was properly made and that no double
stranded cleavage could occur we do this
we did a simple in vitro assay we
incubated the cast line in the case our
MP complex with a super coiled plasmid
the distant part a couple stranded break
would result in a linearized plasmid and
a nick in the plasmid caused it to
unwind and run slower on the gel and can
be seen higher than the super coiled
plasmid which is exactly what can be
seen here in our tests with an average
efficiency of 90% so we now know that we
were able to successfully combined the
nikkei's technology with the RMP
technology next we need to determine if
it can work in human
sells this next proof of concept we
worked on human k562 cells and mortal
leukemia cell line at the emx one locus
which is a transcription factor and a
common CRISPR positive control site
which shows this cell line and locus
because in our hands cells are extremely
easy to culture and transfect and the
locus is open and available to edit em
next I'm gonna go over how we actually
performed the experiments and analyzed
the data while there are a multitude of
different methods to get RMPs into cells
we work with our collaborators max site
flow electroporation system these pace
steps are outlined here you briefly
incubate the cast line and guide RNA to
form an RMP you mix the cells suspended
in a transaction solution and then use
the machine to zap the cells punching
holes in the cell membranes and allowing
our MPs to enter once you allow the
cells to recover you can then harvest
the genomic DNA
another method we use was Lanza's
nucleation which is a transmission
method that has a similar workflow once
we have this genomic DNA they needed to
determine whether any editing took place
historically we have used the cell one
surveyor assay to determine CRISPR
editing and Sullivan's brief run-through
of this is that once you have the
genomic DNA you amplify a region
surrounding the target site of interest
via PCR you can melt andrea Neil the PCR
product by doing so hetero duplexes will
form this diagram here these create
bubbles and the DNA strands permutations
cause mismatches you can then digest the
product with the surveyor nucleus which
cuts single-stranded bubbles cleaving
the DNA strands at the mismatch sites
allowing us to calculate mutations as in
Dells or insertions and deletions after
visually after visually analyzing a gel
this example here
we followed these exact steps targeting
the emx one locus in k562 cells and here
are the results of our first testing we
tested six different conditions first
ourselves alone second ourselves
nucleotide with wild-type SP cast nine
RMP with CR RNA a then wild-type again
with crr nab next our nikkei's our MPs
were nucleic together with Sarah
RNA a and B and the next two are
nikkei's our MPs nucleic 'td alone key
takeaways from these results are that
two single guide wild-type SP cast
landing places have endale percentages
of 23 and 10% and that the paired
indicates our MPs were able to cut at a
similar 22% meaning that the NICUs our
MPs are on par with the current existing
RMP technology another important
takeaway confirmed the in vitro
experiment from earlier in which the
unpaired indicates our MPs have 0%
cleavage efficiency meaning our Necaise
our MPs our own creating single-stranded
nicks and are unable to produce in Dells
alone this is the ideal proof of concept
but it was in an ideal situation with
strong editing seen on both wild-type
our MPs at known strong controls next we
wanted to see whether or not the system
would work if not every guide was a
strong editing guy this is the same
general setup as the previous experiment
with one of the s wild-type SP cast line
our MPs cutting at about 20% but the
difference in this one is that the other
guide in the pair has little to no
visible editing with wild-type SP cast
limit these results while still showing
no editing de paired in the cases
however do not show as clear editing
with with the paired nikkei's there is a
smear as indicated by the red bar on the
gel but I believe
due to the limitations of the sulwon
assay gels cannot accurately show what
is happening at DNA level to remedy this
we decided to do more sequencing based
analysis after this to determine whether
editing actually took place there are
two main types of sequencing based
analysis one involves comparing Sanger
sequencing reads in which PCR products
are sequenced as a pool and the computer
reads overall fluorescence of the pool
as a whole to determine each nucleotide
the other is next generation sequencing
in which each PCR product is sequence
individually in the exact sequence each
strand mutant and wild type is known the
basic steps of NGS are to PCR amplified
the region surrounding the target site
of the genomic DNA just like the other
methods you then however deviate and
prep the PCR product with specific
adapters for NGS sequencing before
running them on a specialized sequencer
specialty bioinformatics tools are then
used to analyze results and determine
the nature and quantities of each
mutation type this is a much more
accurate method of analysis than cell
one so we decided to use the same
genomic DNA of a few of the samples of
the previously unclear cell one results
and then performed NGS on them this is a
mutation frequency plot of the previous
cell one data which shows the percentage
of editing at each base pair along the
sequencing rate controlled DNA reads are
in green wild type SP cast line edited
DNA reads are in blue paired nikkei's
cast line edited DNA reads are in pink
and unpaired in a case cast line edited
DNA is in yellow this NGS analysis
showed us that yes this in the case
guide pair was functioning correctly it
was just that our assay was unable to
recognize it
across across both guide sites there is
on average 10% editing with the paradin
occasion
another big takeaway is as you can see
the wild type SP cast line is very
strong editing at a single spot it shows
up clearly on the cell one si nikkei's
editing is much more spread out showing
up as the smear on a gel we believe this
can allow for editing events along a
much wider window than just a single
guide along
perhaps encouraging larger knockouts
incidentally it also shows that the
unpaired Necaise leaves the DNA
completely unedited with every base pair
along the cut site being completely
identical to the unedited wild-type DNA
proving the specificity of our system at
the nucleotide level because of the
dramatic increase in data fidelity from
here on out we used sequencing based
analysis on all important results we
repeated this experiment in triplicate
and we're excited to see editing in NGS
that was not seen in the Selwyn SHS not
only that but our paired NIC case our MP
design was able to edit in a region a
wild-type SP cast line was not able to
edit in well as 10% as our usual cutoff
for and and in addition when alone
leaves the DNA completely unedited this
test was another great proof of concept
for the technology we were able to show
paired NIC a system working well in
multiple different locations as well as
confirming that any possibility of off
targeting is negated by showing that
even at the strong on target location
where wild-type SP cast lion cubs at 40%
there is no editing seen when the
unpaired nikkei's nicks at that location
if a perfect guide match at a strong
location results in zero editing with an
unpaired in a case any imperfect
complementarity to the guide at an off
target site will result in zero editing
as well
the combination of efficiency in
specificity make this technology
incredibly useful for therapeutic
applications so we wanted to test to see
how well they can perform to the more
relevant target on a more relevant and
call oncology cell line for this we
decided to test the system in cd8
positive primary t-cells at PB 1 locus
as I'm sure you're all aware PT 1 is a
clinically relevant target in oncology
it has been shown that a way cancer
cells evade detection is to utilize
immune checkpoint molecules to
circumvent an immune system response
t-cell would see these and assume that
the cancer cell is no normal encode
dormant one such negative regulator of
t-cell activity is the ligand PDL one
found on tumor cells and it functions by
the binding of program to death one or
PD one a receptor on activated T cells
the anti-tumor effect of T cells can be
improved by blocking the PD one receptor
which has been shown to increase the
immune response against cancer cells and
it is a safer and more effective
technique than attempting to act on the
cancer itself this is known as
checkpoint inhibition and in doing so
increases the wakefulness of the T cells
in regard to cancer cell fighting this
checkpoint inhibition is a very well
known technique and it has been done
with antibodies z offends talyn's and
even other CRISPR systems however each
method has has has had known drawbacks
via price ease or specificity most if
not all of these drawbacks can be solved
with our new paired nikkei's RMP system
so we went to work and design some
guides that target PG one we wanted to
quickly test to see if the system was
functional the guides we designed for PT
1 were able to work so we did a quick
experiment in k562 cells this is a cell
one gel that shows that each guide
achieves 1 to 15% in
dells alone with wild-type SP cast nine
but interestingly we see that they
appear to function even better as a
paired system with 17 to 25 percent in
bells in the paired Nikkei system even
when using the 1% editing guide this is
a very promising initial testing of the
target but we needed to move forward on
to the testing in cd8 positive primary
t-cells to see if the editing can be
functionally used up until this point
we've been using a two-part synthetic
guide RNA in our armed assistance there
are two different forms of synthetic
guider and you can use a two-part or a
single guide in the two-part system a
universal tracer RNA and a target
specific CR RNA are annealed before
being complexed into a single guide well
in the single guide system the entire
guide RNA is synthesized in one piece
both can be used to increase can be
modified to increase efficiency and
stability historically the two-part
system is cheaper to synthesize and
works well in immortal cell lines in our
hands but as we tried to move these
experiments into primary cells we were
unable to get any of the in Dells we had
previously seen ten to twenty percent in
Dells that we had previously seen in
k562 cells dropped to near undetectable
levels recent papers have shown that
chemically modified a single guide RNA
our M keys have enhanced cast line
editing in human primary cells so we've
repeated these experiments with the new
modified single guides to verify this
claim the difference in the results with
the new guides and our primary key cells
was staggering from seeing little to no
editing whatsoever in any of our
previously very strong guide pairs just
similar and even better in Del
percentage than what was seen in
immortal cell lines up to 50% from sub
2% this new addition are paired in a
case RMP system was fully functional in
primary cell lines so we could go
forward with a full
see they're editing potential here is
the same data made with single guide RNA
modified but with the full panel
including wild-type SP cast 9 and
triplet
you see strong cutting above 10% across
the board for all conditions with one
paired in the case having the highest
editing of the lot this is a much more
relevant proof of concept than a MUX one
in k562 cells our paired NIC a system is
now working just as effectively as the
wild-type esti cast line system in PBMCs
the next test would be confirming the
specificity of the system that we saw in
k562 cells carryover which is exactly
what we did our team tested the SP cast
line in a case with only the single
guides and then the two paired together
and the results here confirmed that zero
editing is taking place when the new
cases are transfected alone in a primary
cell line proving that the specificity
we saw an immortal cell lines translates
to primary cell lines as well putting
all of this together we now know that we
have a highly specific editing system
with high cutting efficient cutting
efficiency in a relevant cell line at a
relevant clinical target the next step
is to determine if the editing being
performed by this system is actually
phenotypic ly knocking out the protein
of interest and not just in
significantly Gino typically editing
sequence
we work with our collaborator max Lee to
perform pv-1 immunostaining and flow
cytometry analysis to determine the
expression levels of pd-1 after being
edited with SP cast 9 with prepared Nick
a system in triplicate
they transfected our MPs into cells with
a flow electroporation system let the
cells recover and perform analysis at
three time points what you can see here
is that at all PI minerals there is a
greater phenotypic knockout of pd-1 in
PM VCS using the Nikkei system and using
SP cast nine alone even though the
genotypic in del percentage was
comparable between the two conditions
you can see that the Knockouts after
five days in the wild-type SP cast line
system have up to a 40% drop in
expression while in the paired Nikkei
system that's more than double with over
an 80 percent drop in expression
compared to control levels we
hypothesize that this is because as we
saw earlier in the mutation frequency
plot paradin in case editing spreads out
its in Del's
across a much wider area than a single
guide system we beam to larger knockouts
causing more of a phenotypic disruption
than wild-type SD cast line does this
makes it an even more effective tool for
therapeutic purposes than we had
previously hypothesized however when
talking about phenotypes we next had to
make sure that the nikkei system cannot
cause off target phenotype effects in a
crisper eye fashion even if in the case
itself has repeatedly shown that it did
not edit DNA at the genotype level be
tested this in the same fashion as the
previous test excite transfected the
nikkei's RMP with a single guide alone
and waited a hundred and twenty hours
before measuring the PD one expression
levels in the cells what you can see
here is that in an unpaired indicate
system after five days the expression
levels are identical to the wild-type
controls
this is at the same time point and
conditions that the paired indicate
system dropped expression levels by over
80% repeating this in triplicate
verified that the system remains highly
specific even on the protein expression
level putting everything together again
we now have a crisper cast editing
system with high efficiency in both in
delft percentage in phenotypic knockout
without the possibility of any off
targeting effects on the sequencing or
gene expression level exactly the type
of system a scientist and the
therapeutic realm needs to ensure the
only thing they're changing in cells of
what they designed it to do we wanted to
expand our scope and test this new
system in a variety of immunotherapy
targets and t-cells to ensure that the
system is just as flexible as wild-type
SPS 9 is we're gonna do this we look
through different checkpoint
immunotherapy literature's and found in
three other candidates for protein
targets that have potential therapeutic
significance and design our guides to
target these low side ckle for Tim three
in PRA C we went through all the
preliminary steps as before for
validation testing in immortal cell
lines and such before moving forward
into testing in CDA positive primary
t-cells what you can see here are the
results of these tests performed in
triplicate
while the editing efficiency varies from
target to target has all cast line
systems do our paired net gate system
it's significant editing results across
the board and the high specificity of
these results will carry over making it
an excellent choice for future CRISPR
immunotherapy applications in research
for scientists who want to have high
efficiency in specificity in their
results thank you for listening you can
read more about our work and see these
results more in depth in our paper that
was recently submitted to the bio
archives
thank you